I want you all to think that for a minute you are living in New York City and you don't
own a car, the subway is running late, Uber rides are too expensive, you can actually
still hop onto a city bike.
It's small, it's readily available, it gets you to your destination, it can drop it off.
Just be careful when you're riding one in New York City.
So that is how I would actually present some of the data on KTX1001 in heavily pre-treated
relapsed refractory myeloma patients.
So we know that 4-14 translocation is seen in about 10-15% of all new myeloma and some
marker of high, more aggressive disease biology.
And these patients with 4-14 translocation tend to have higher levels of MM-set expression
that actually leads to epigenetic signaling and myeloma cell proliferation.
And what essentially KTX does is that it actually binds to the MM-set, puts some brakes on the
MM-set and actually decreases the levels of H3K36 molecules and then leads to downregulation
of oncogenic signals.
So it's a very interesting study.
So we're going to go through the link.
It has been explored for relapsed refractory myeloma in our phase one study.
A total of 40 patients were enrolled in the study in nine different dosing cohorts.
The inclusion criteria did require patients to have exposure to PI, IMIDs, and CD38 antibody,
have measurable disease and adequate performance status.
KTX was given as an oral agent without dexamethasone, given twice daily, again, and nine different
dosing cohorts.
And I would focus on this patient demographic slide here that you can see.
40 patients were enrolled and 100% of them were triple-class refractory.
In fact, 40% of them had a prior BCMA CAR-T, 60% of them had a prior BCMA bispecific or
ADC, and another 40% of them, in fact, had a GPRC5D or FCRH5 Bispecific.
Patient has a median of six prior lines of therapy.
And 80% of them are in fact penta-exposed.
414 translocation was in about 50% of the patient and remaining 25% either had deletion 17P or
1q amplification.
So truly, a heavily pre-treated relapsed refractory myeloma patient population that doesn't really
have a lot of options left behind.
Looking at the primary objective of the study, which is safety assessment, major dose limiting
toxicity was thrombocytopenia.
Grade three or higher events were seen in about 20% of the patients.
Grade three neutropenia or anemia is only in about 25% of the patients.
So more impact on the platelet count and the hemoglobin and ANC.
Very few cases of febrile neutropenia of only 5%.
When you look at non-heme AEEs, you only see about 10% case of grade three fatigue and
infections in these patients.
And looking at the efficacy, again, remember, this is a heavily pre-treated patient population.
We are looking at different dose levels and we are only giving it as a monotherapy without
dexamethasone.
And yet we are seeing responses of stable disease are better seen in about 40% of the
patients.
Many of these responses are stable disease.
There were few partial responses as well.
And one of the patients actually achieved a VGPR that lasted beyond 12 months.
We did see that with the administration of KTX, there was a diminishing in the size or
measurement of HTK86 in the peripheral blood, as well as in the bone marrow.
And we did in fact see a decreased proliferation in the tumor, as well as increased proliferation
in the immune cells.
And here is actually one of my patients who was part of the presentation at ASH, a 60-year-old
gentleman who got diagnosed with multiple myeloma in 2015, has been at MSK for a long
period of time, had received at least two transplants, had received quadruple therapy
as well, had BCMA bispecifics, CAR-T, GPRC, 5D therapy, in total 16 prior lines of therapy
with extra medullary disease and rising free light chains at a time they got enrolled on
the KTX.
And even when the patient got started on KTX, they actually had an increase in the free
light chains.
But within a month's time, we started noticing that the light chains started trickling down,
and eventually the patient achieved very good partial response that lasted beyond a year.
Eventually, the patients succumbed to their disease with extra medullary disease, but
we did notice any response to EMD as well, just with the monotherapy with KTX.
So in conclusion, KTX is a selective inhibitor of MMSAT and NSD2.
It has shown us tolerable safety profile, it has actually shown some efficacy in heavily
predated myeloma patients, there are ongoing trials that are actually looking at combinations
of KTX with carfilazomab as well as with cell mods like mezignamide.
I do think in the era where we are using CAR-T and bispecifics in the frontline settings,
the patients that are relapsed or refractory a few years from now are going to be refractory
to a lot of the options that we have available right now in the form of CAR-T and bispecifics.
So molecules like KTX would actually be an option for MMSAT.
many of these patients especially when we are looking at targeted therapy as well thank you